c'est le roi des animaux
lui s'appelle saïd ski en arabe veut
dire joie mais ce jeune fille on n'a
certainement pas ressenti cette joie au
cours des premières années de sa vie
saïd ça il était traumatisé il ne
faisait que tremblay war on estime qu'il
ya environ 2
il n'a connu que la guerre avant
d'arriver ici maintenant
saïd a été secouru avec 13 autres
animaux en syrie les seuls survivants
sur quelque 300 gardes et dans un zoo
près d'alep
tous avaient été laissés pour compte
dans une ville qui a connu l'un des
chapitres les plus violents de la guerre
là-bas on les a retrouvés dans un état
lamentable affamés et déshydratés et
traumatisé par le bruit constant des
combats et des explosions au néant quand
ils sont arrivés ils étaient tous émacié
que la peau et les os heureusement said
n'avait pas de plaie ouverte
contrairement à d'autres animaux qui en
était couvert et qui étaient traumatisés
ils ont été soignés à brevets et nourrit
en urgence et pour se remettre de ce
cauchemar
ils ont été transportés ici en jordanie
sanctuaire al marwa près de saïd simba
dont l'histoire tout aussi tragique a
pris forme à mossoul en irak reprend lui
aussi du poil de la bête
we know that simba vu son père mourir
sa mère a dévoré son père parce qu'il
n'y avait tout simplement rien à manger
un traumatisme pour un jeune lion il a
environ quatre ans et commence à peine à
avoir une crinière ils n'en avaient pas
du tout à son arrivée et avait l'air
d'une petite femelle mais avec une
nourriture appropriée et la médication
et les nutriments dont il a besoin
ces hormones se développe et il devient
maintenant un lion c'est beau à voir
ces images prises au moment de
l'expiration de simba montre bien les
conditions abjectes et souvent mortel
dans lesquelles les animaux se
retrouvent quand les hommes se battent
et que le sort des bêtes se retrouve
bien au bas de la liste des priorités
les missions de sauvetage pour ces
grands oubliés sont organisées par
l'organisme de charité fort pas
internationaux des opérations complexes
qui exigent des mois de préparation et
de négociation les équipes doivent
souvent composer avec plusieurs
contrôles sécuritaires qui parsèment les
territoires qu'elles doivent traverser
contrôlés par des partis opposés dans
les conflits
chaque passage exige une permission
chaque kilomètre parcouru représente un
risque comme out diana bernath est
originaire de chaouaou canada y dirige
sanctuaire al marwa en jordanie
il a quitté une carrière dans le milieu
corporatif pour poursuivre sa passion
pour les grands animaux meurent les
animaux n'ont pas choisi d'être mise en
cage ni de voir leur gardien jeté la clé
comment peuvent-ils se débrouiller pour
survivre au milieu des bombardements il
n'y a pas à manger ni à boire
ils ne peuvent pas simplement se lever
et partir
ils sont coincés je suis reconnaissante
que des gens au grand coeur aide ces
animaux et c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce
qu'on fait l'os l'os diana et le
personnel du sanctuaire permettent à ces
réfugiés sur quatre pattes de se refaire
une santé de manger à leur faim une
alimentation adaptée à leur espèce est
de retrouver un peu de confiance
certains ces félins pourront se
prélasser ici pour le restant de leurs
jours
c'est le cas de ce groupe de lyon ils
n'ont pas connu la guerre mais sont
victime de la cupidité de l'homme ils
ont été sauvés après avoir été mise en
vente pour quelques centaines de dollars
alors qu'il avait à peine quatre jours
impossible de penser les remettre en
liberté une fois depuis leur naissance
ils n'ont connu que la captivité ils ne
savent pas comment survivre dans la
nature et à la mousse de même les
animaux sauvages sont en danger si nous
voulions les transporter en afrique du
sud ou ailleurs en afrique d'où
proviennent ces lions
il serait menacé il y à du braconnage
ici nous savons qu'ils sont en sécurité
[Musique]
kate sayid et simba ont repris à cette
force pour être transportée jusqu'en
afrique du sud où ils passeront le reste
de leur vie dans un autre sanctuaire une
source de fierté pour diana mais les
adieux à ses pensionnaires sont toujours
déchirant on déteste le voir partir
c'est un nos favoris mais c'est pour le
mieux
l'histoire de saïd et simba se poursuit
sur une note beaucoup plus positive
qu'elle n'a commencé les avec le cycle
incessant de conflit dans la région
il cède une place précieuse qui sera
malheureusement bien vite comblé par
d'autres rescapés
[Musique]